ladies and gentlemen boys and girls it's
here it is finally time eldon ring is
coming out in just a couple days from me
filming this video it has felt like an
eternity since the announcement trailer
came out last november i think but these
last couple weeks man have just been
brutal but we're right there we're in
the home stretch waiting for this game
to come out and from software released a
launch trailer today i thought you know
what i'm gonna be making elden ring
content like crazy so why not start our
new eldon ring journey here on youtube
with the launch trailer every trailer
that from software has made has been an
absolute banger so sit back relax and
enjoy the elden ring launch trailer i
wonder how much more of this game
they're actually gonna show us because
it feels like they've shown us
so much already
and then they'll come out and say that
it's what we've shown to you all is not
that much i'm like
oh my god
i am so excited
that which he desire
oh
lord
be as a god
a god
see i don't i don't know that much of
the lore of what's going on really
he will be forsaken
so oh my god
it's the wing of a dragon
oh
i already have chills man
i think what they've shown us i've
wow looks like irithyll
[Music]
we've heard this quote before in uh in
other trailers for sure
wow
that is sick oh my god
yo
is that his is that his voice
i forget his name
wow man
whoa
got a snake
[Music]
it's kind of a vibe shift okay
like some skyrim [ __ ]
oh my god what is that against the
earthquake
never met someone with a test with
bronco
lobster what the
that's some dark souls 2
[ __ ] right there
and once all is done
we shall see each other
once more raise the flame baby praise
the sun
wow it looks so beautiful
[Music]
it's a couple of fingers like like this
oh my god
oh my god
available february 25th so it releases
in a weird way i'm gonna throw up what
they posted on how they're going to
release the games for me i'm central
time zone in north america so the game
for me comes out on february 24th at 5
00 pm central because i'm gonna be
playing it on pc if you're on console it
looks like you're gonna have to be
waiting a few more hours to play the
game i am so sorry but they're obviously
doing that to manage the networks of how
many people are gonna be playing this
game all at the same time it's extremely
smart for them to do this but here's the
overall map or the time frame wherever
you're from that's when it's coming out
but this trailer was
gorgeous i mean just walking up the side
of a dragon bro right next to the i
don't know what it's called the elden
tree or something that you know all the
trees we've seen in all the marketing
this looks so beautiful i have not seen
this area
whatsoever in any other trailer we've
seen they showed us a lot of new stuff
here which i'm really surprised about
but the traversal methods it seems from
the gameplay that i've seen from the
trailers that they've shown us reversal
is not gonna be like okay here's one
path of a road or go across this bridge
there's gonna be lots of different ways
to go anywhere on the map or secret ways
to get up on to certain areas of the map
i love that [ __ ] it's not gonna be like
skyrim where you have to traverse weird
glitches up a mountain to get where you
want to get it's gonna be a part of the
game and that's what from software has
nailed with every dark souls game
especially dark souls one intricate
level design making it so the paths of
the game intersect with each other
beautifully and imagine if they can do
this on a scale this size i i know
they're gonna [ __ ] pull it off i know
this game is gonna be a
game of the year best games one of the
best games we've ever played in our
lives i think that's almost a guarantee
at this point i don't see them [ __ ]
up this game in any way now again i've
been let down before okay i've been let
down a few times all right this area
right here looks like irithyll valley
from dark souls 3 but like inside of a
cave i don't know what this guy's gonna
be doing like this is obviously uh the
castle that we saw in the network tests
where you fight gold when the or the
yeah god win the golden or something
like that beforehand well this guy's
like shooting [ __ ] cannonballs that's
like flaming cannonballs at us this
guy's coming back gonna show us the
giant battlefield that we're gonna have
to fight this guy on this part was kind
of weird i don't know i don't know why i
felt kind of weird about this part like
the snake dude right here is she
resurrecting a dragon is this a player
that you can play as there's an npc look
at though there's multiple dragons
little baby dragons right here in the
big dragon they're all rising up with
this spell this right here is beautiful
is this woman or or whatever this thing
is being held up by
by the ring like right look at that it
looks like
something out of the bible dude like
what is this is this like the
transparent ring in a different
dimension like
holding certain people up i have no idea
what's going on and then they throw in
this lobster just annihilating this guy
i love it oh bro this game looks so
beautiful like so much detail so oh my
god look at that what is going on here
that's all i'm going to be saying
throughout the entire my first entire
playthrough is going to be like what is
that what is going on oh my god oh guys
i am so [ __ ] excited i hope you guys
are too i just cussed a lot i'm really i
apologize but i could not be happier
with everything that we've seen it's
right around the corner i man i know you
guys are as pumped as i am and if you're
watching this video bro we gotta i gotta
do something for the next couple days
i'm gonna be lifting weights working out
going on runs oh my god just a waste
time until 5 pm on thursday for me hey
guys i appreciate you watching this
video thank you very much if you enjoyed
the video want to see more elden ring
content from myself make sure to leave a
like post a comment tell me what you
enjoyed what you'd like to see and
obviously make sure to subscribe it
helps out a ton we're trying to grow our
community as big as we possibly can this
year hey i love you guys man go tell
someone else you love them as well have
a great day peace out